so evidence clear right I mean we could
go on and on and on sharing all the
evidence for China's good guilt but I
think you get the point all right
there's no evidence on the other side
that China is somehow not guilty for
this CBS News doesn't want to hear it
CBS News on 60 minutes which is very
major television news program highly
respected been around for a long time 60
minutes is doing its level best to get
China off the hook and to actually place
blame not just on Europe but even on the
United States so he just listened to the
kind of language they use to cover for
China why did the president just cancel
da Saks funding it's the kind of
politics which might seem ill-advised
in a health crisis President Trump is
blaming China's government for the
pandemic the outbreak was first detected
in the city of Wuhan the administration
has said at times the viruses man-made
or that if it's natural it must have
leaked out of a Chinese government lab
both the White House and the Chinese
Communist Party have been less than
honest and so in China and in the u.s.
the work of scientists like peter ducek
is being undercut by pandemic politics
so just stop it right there for a moment
you see what he does he says so the big
dishonesty here is that the United
States said that this might have come
from a lab which by the way every single
day it seems more and more likely that
this virus came from the lab as as not
just senators but as other scientists
have been talking about as well and he
says but look and maybe China hasn't
been totally honest but it's mostly the
other examples I'm going to give you or
how the United States hasn't been honest
and so at the very least we can say both
sides haven't been honest it's this
false equivalency between China which
created the virus one way or another
whether it was made in nature and then
observed in the Wuhan laboratory or
whether it was made in nature and just
happened to escape into the world
because of these Wuhan wet markets
because of these unsafe food practices
which by the way does not
seem very likely but even if it were
that is China's fault and they're lying
about it and then the United States
calls them out for it but because it's
not 100% certain that that's what
happened because we don't know because
trying to cover it up then you're saying
the United States is also dishonest
bizarre behavior especially for an
allegedly American television news
program then he tries to pull out and
say look there's really just this third
party called the scientists and they're
the ones that we need to follow and both
of the political actors China in the
United States they're basically both the
same and so don't give the u.s. any more
credit than you give to China then he
goes on to defend even more the alleged
objectivity untouchability of the
scientists the Wuhan Institute is
internationally respected two years ago
a team from the US Embassy visited that
team sent a cable to Washington
concerned that one lab in the complex
had a serious shortage of trained
investigators but the cable first
reported by The Washington Post
emphasize the Wuhan Institute is
critical to future outbreak prediction
and Prevention so what this guy just did
is what I call the compliment sandwich
it's what a lot of flatterers will do to
and it's that what a lot of PR people
will do if they want to break some bad
news they'll say a really a good thing
then they'll put the criticism in there
and then they'll say another really good
thing so he opens up he says the Wuhan
Institute of biology is internationally
respected no I don't think it is I think
actually it's the least respected lab in
the world right now
I think people hate the damn Institute
of Virology in Wuhan because it gave us
this global plague so no it's not
internationally respected also how do I
know it's not internationally respected
because the very next thing he says is
you know some some US inspectors pointed
out that it wasn't very safe but but but
it was only one lab and it wasn't all it
wasn't all the places and but yeah it
wasn't very safe okay well if it's not
very safe then how on earth would you
call it internationally respected and
actually the people pointed out there
wasn't safe we're international in China
and then they say but it's very
important this lab is very important in
fighting diseases no it clearly isn't it
would appear that the lab is very
important in spreading diseases so a one
good way to fight those diseases might
be to shut down the lab and not fund it
as we in the United States did and as a
lot of people including dr. pouchy seem
to be involved with this decision to
fund the laboratory but that's the
compliment sandwich it's a really great
lab yeah okay they might have started
this global pandemic but it's a really
great lab then we get to the real
criticism of America we so far we
haven't had any criticism of China just
about but then we get to the criticism
of America the victim of this crime
China's the perpetrator America's the
victim CBS blames the victim I mean this
we are now in a case where you have a
rapist and a victim and CBS 6 is 60
minutes is covering it and they say well
she was wearing an awfully short skirt
well she shouldn't been out in that
neighborhood at night I mean that that
is the kind of victim blaming you hear
that phrase from the left a lot this is
a perfect example of that
victim blaming from the mainstream media
you have the compliment sandwich then
CBS gets to the hard work of blaming
America eco Health's work with luhan
ended one week after mr. Trump's
briefing room pledge when the NIH
revoked the grant initially President
Trump praised China but in the following
weeks testing in the u.s. failed to
catch up to the need vital equipment was
short bodies filled refrigerated
trailers and science was continuously
challenged as the u.s. led the world in
illness and death the White House moved
the focus to the Chinese government
nothing that he just said is true
nothing not I don't think one syllable
of that was true
initially he blames America for
defunding the Wuhan laboratory as if
this is some great tragedy you know what
if you start a global pandemic if you're
and I'm not saying they constructed the
virus right this is the left-wing trick
they
there is no evidence that they
constructed the virus in the lab nobody
is saying they constructed the virus
we're simply saying that the virus was
very likely present in the lab and may
have escaped and a lot of evidence is
suggesting that that was the case
they're saying they're trying to
obviously fight a straw man because they
can't argue against that pretty salient
observation he says defunding the Wuhan
Lab was a terrible idea if starting a
global pandemic is not enough to get
your lab defunded then there is no
criterion for getting your lab defunded
of course we should have done that then
he says the bodies started piling up in
the United States as the United States
led the world and death and carnage no
we didn't China did but China is lying
about their numbers you can follow every
other country on earth you look at the
progression of the virus it goes up up
up right then there maybe there's a
little plateau but it keeps following
this pattern with China it goes up up up
and then one day it just completely
drops down now do you think that's
because the Chinese people have some
amazing fact of their biology that all
on one day just shuts down viruses do
you think that the Chinese have some
amazing magic some wizardry where they
wave a wand and then just one day
magically the virus goes away or is the
Communist Party lying about their
numbers guess what it's the latter how
do we know that they actually admitted
they were lying about the numbers
they're still lying but they admitted
that the numbers out of Wuhan were not
true so that total total shill for the
the Chinese Communist Party then he
keeps going on and says science was
being denied in the United States
science was being denied who's denying
science here though the one who believes
that the virus just magically
disappeared in China one day the one who
believes that the laboratory that very
likely started this pandemic still
should be funded though the who which
science is being denied which model
because all the models contradicted each
other and it turns out they were all
wrong too who is denying science he of
course is treating science as though
it's a sort of religious faith you could
you could be a denier but you know then
you're a heretic you ought to be burned
at the stake practically when in fact
science
oh I could do a whole episode on the
word sign the word science just means
knowledge right that's it comes from
Shia de the Latin word she died - no and
the the word has been so politicized now
that one-one political interest group
the these materialists people who engage
in a very modern study of empirical
material investigation have now
monopolized the entire word for
knowledge that's a whole other issue but
it does play into the politics here
because what he is saying when he talks
about science being tonight is we know
everything we know it we have we have a
monopoly on the facts we have a monopoly
on information and it's being denied by
mean old conservatives like Donald Trump
and that is why the US has led the world
in death and destruction none of which
is true and then he takes one final
swipe to defend China that's where this
began last Sunday Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo attempted to resurrect a
debunked theory that the virus was
man-made in China there it is did I
predict it I predicted it
it's a debunk theory that the virus was
man-made first of all that's not
debunked till you debunk that theory we
know very little about this virus to
begin with but second of all nobody's
saying it was man-made we're saying it
had something to do with the laboratory
those are two completely different
things
and because the CCP's lapdogs and the
american media can't actually argue
against what appears to be pretty likely
that the the lab had something to do
with the virus they try to argue against
this straw man
[Music]
you
[Music]